how does one discover life on other
planets well the first thing you need
are other planets going around our Sun
are eight planets plus Pluto and a bunch
of moons and lots of other stuff but
it's a small selection so your best bet
is to look for planets going around any
and all stars our galaxy alone is a
hundred billion stars in it and so there
is a lot of hope of seeing an enormous
amount of planets as long as we have a
way of seeing them here are some ways
you can see planets going around other
stars the first is the transit method
the transit method is a method of seeing
a planet by watching for it block the
light of the star in other words if the
planet is reasonably big compared to the
star when it orbits the star it could
get in our way and we would see that the
light from the star dims and then
brightens again with this very specific
pattern which would be caused by a
planet transiting in front of it and in
fact at this point thousands of planets
going around other stars have been seen
using the transit method a second method
that people use is a method basically
looking for the wobble of a star a
planet like Jupiter can be quite heavy
even compared to the star such that when
it goes around the star the star wobbles
and when it wobbles towards and away
from us it shifts the frequency of light
that's coming towards us it's called a
Doppler shift and that Doppler shift
happening at a very regular pattern
period tells us that there's something
heavy going around it
a third way is if stars and planets pass
in between us and more distant bright
stars that passing can cause the light
to be warped a little bit it's called
gravitational lensing predicted by
Einstein all these methods and more our
hopes for seeing thousands tens of
thousands even hundreds of thousands of
planets in the near and mediate future
but then you want to figure out if
there's life on any of those planets how
are we gonna do that well the best bet
is to look at the atmosphere the
atmosphere will contain all kinds of
chemicals and those chemicals could have
been naturally there due to the
formation of the planet in the first
place or they could be there because
something interesting is happening on
the surface of the planet giants planets
like Jupiter and bigger naturally have
water in their atmospheres but tiny
rocky planets shouldn't and they
shouldn't because sunlight breaks apart
water and hydrogen is so light it wants
to escape light planets so look for
small rocky planets that have lots of
water in their atmosphere already that
will suggest that there is water on the
surface of the rocky planet like oceans
it doesn't prove there's life on the
planet but at least now we're getting
more evidence and we're seeing ways of
seeing planets that look more and more
like the earth a final stage would be to
look at that atmosphere and find other
things in the atmosphere with abundances
amounts that are unexpected to occur
simply naturally one of those is for
example oxygen oxygen can be something
which is produced by living organisms so
if you look at a planet and in its
atmosphere there is water and there's
large levels of oxygen and perhaps other
chemicals that we might expect to be
produced by the processes of life then
we start to have strong evidence for the
existence of life to really go the final
step you need really provable
theoretical models of what life can and
cannot do and what non-life processes
can do and put chemicals into the
atmosphere as to how are we going to be
sure we don't know other than let's say
direct communication with the
intelligent beings out there
however we do see a path to get closer
and closer to eventually answering that
question are we alone